happy Star Wars Friday youtubers we got
to talk about the Knights of Ren there's
new evidence that they might be working
on a spin-off film for them let me know
what you guys think of the new Rick and
Morty background - I thought it was time
for a change I've had the Minecraft
thing for forever but if you're new to
the channel I do Star Wars videos every
week be sure to subscribe to get
everything
there's even a Star Wars giveaway going
on now that I'll explain at the end of
the video but we got to talk about the
Knights of Ren in the spin-off movies so
last year JJ Abrams teed up the idea you
know I'd really like to see a movie
about the Knights of Ren something that
he introduced in the force awakens what
do you want to see in a future anthology
film in the Star Wars universe I got to
say you know Kathy Kennedy who's running
it all uh she seems to be sort of you
know hitting all the right uh pressure
on the right buttons I mean I I feel
like there isn't something that I would
love to see I mean that visit I guess
the one I would say is there's a nice of
rennes story that could be pretty cool
just to tell just this really badass
group working for Snoke the way the
inquisitors were working for the Emperor
during the rebels period if you don't
watch the rebels cartoon they actually
just got renewed for season four obi-wan
is getting ready for a rematch with
Darth Maul this weekend they have a
group of Darkseid force users of varying
levels of abilities some of them are
fallen light side Jedi's that are very
powerful some of them only have
rudimentary Force training but they're
the Emperor's dogs of war that hunt down
the last of the Jedi to kill them so in
the force awakens or at least in the new
trilogy Snoke has a group that's like
this that's led by kylo Ren he's named
after the Knights of Ren so I don't want
to call it their Suicide Squad film but
just because Star Wars typically
revolves around really good characters
doesn't mean that they couldn't also do
a film about big bill and characters but
depending on which order you watch them
in all six previous saga films have
revolved around Darth Vader so you could
argue that all the films are about
villains they just have a lot of heroes
in them doing the Knights of Ren
spin-off film would just be a cool way
to take up on new characters and do some
things that they haven't done before
they still have
confirm what that third solo movie is
going to be they'll probably way either
till celebration this year or
celebrations the year that the Han Solo
movie comes out which is still a couple
years away we got that brief flash of
them during the force awakens but we
learned a little bit about them in the
expanded canon in the visual dictionary
there's a new theory that they were
formed out of the acolytes of the beyond
which is a group that served Palpatine
before the fall of the empire then spun
into Stokes new first order and has he
appropriated all their resources it
stands to reason that he would also seek
to create his own special forces team
the way that Palpatine did in the
aftermath book series which is canon we
meet the group the acolytes of beyond
they try to find Darth Vader's
lightsaber and return it to him in debt
but it's only the beginning so you have
this group of darkside worshippers it's
sort of like a dark version of the
Church of the force it worshiped Darth
Vader the way that kylo Ren did many
years later he has his helmet it makes
sense that aspects of that group would
blow into the Knights of Ren because
they talked about something very
powerful coming from beyond now they
could be speaking in metaphors but
because the aftermath book series takes
place in between the old films in the
new films it makes sense the very
powerful thing they say is coming is
actually Snoke so he comes he forms the
Knights of Ren the really cool thing
about the name Ren is that it means
rebirth in the Hindu culture
so the acolytes of the beyond are more
interested in the rebirth of Darth Vader
but in a way so is kylo Ren so wouldn't
it make sense that he becomes the
rebirth of Darth Vader now this is all
self described I don't believe that he's
actually the rebirth of baiter
but I think that he wants to believe
that so much grandfather
show me the visions again
shall be again the power of the darkness
and I will let nothing stand in our way
show me grandfather and I will finish
what you started
so he wants to bring order to the galaxy
I mean he's a little bit crazy but he's
not completely insane he does have a
plan and we're supposed to learn about
it in the next film how about idolizes
Darth Vader but Darth Vader turned good
so why does Chiron idolized off Vader so
much if he's bad kylo Ren idolizes Darth
Vader not Anakin Skywalker okay he
idolizes this what beta represents and
what what Vader was trying to do and the
idea that Vader didn't succeed he was if
you look at it from Ren's point of view
he was he was seduced by the enemy and
failed because of that seduction and so
the idea is that Ren wants to complete
the thing that Vader started that's
super interesting man was really good
boys inside Ren made him turn bad an
incredible power an incredible force an
incredible potential that was like with
many young people sort of misguided and
unclear and the story for him is one of
conflict not just external conflict but
internal conflict as what makes him I
think a rather interesting villain but
you can see how these sequence of events
lead to the creation of the Knights of
Ren group worshiping Darth Vader after
he's died seek to communicate with him
in death eventually kylo Ren comes along
the grandson of Vader Snoke appropriates
him they seek the rebirth of Vader and
twist his mind what we don't know is at
what point kylo Ren became the Vader
fanboy seeking to bring about his dark
vision for the galaxy the way they've
been presented in the narrative is very
seductive but we learned that kylo Ren
got in a lot of trouble as a child
that's one of the reasons why Leia sent
him to study with Luke because he had so
much potential and when you have
potential that's wasted usually people
have crazy ways of lashing out in their
frustration so imagine you're Ben solo
and you find this group that's
worshipping your father it can be
incredibly seductive but I think the
idea of rebirth Knights of Ren all flows
from Snoke that's something that he
created to be his special forces so
Snoke is basically taking gasoline and
throwing it on the flame that is kylo
Ren's ego saying you have purpose you're
the rebirth of Vader giving him that
Hindu name of rebirth so now you start
to understand why it is he's working
with Snoke even though it seems like
he's doing really bad
it's all the way you spin it we're doing
this to bring order to the galaxy to get
rid of the old ways of the Jedi and
create something new it is the from Luke
Skywalker's perspective from a distance
what they're creating is very evil very
ominous and when you hear about what
Snoke and the first order did to
discredit Luke then you start to realize
what's going on were they to do a
Knights of Ren movie they would probably
try to do something of a prequel because
kylo Ren even though he became the
leader of the Knights of Ren his alter
ego name is kylo Ren Snoke had people he
trained before Ben solo so there was a
Knights of Ren before Ben solo came
along so you do a film more about them
and you would keep kylo Ren in the saga
films Gareth Edwards actually confirm
recently that they are committed to not
making the future saga films about
legacy characters so they're talking
about Luke Leia Han Solo all the
characters that you've known and left
for a long time they have all this new
Canon they're introducing all these new
characters they'll be exploring that
going forward which i think is a good
thing for Star Wars to remain healthy
you have to bring in new blood and that
doesn't mean that they won't include
characters that we've seen before
there's talk of the new saga characters
coming back for another trilogy after
they're done with this one nothing's
confirm the big takeaway is there's not
going to be a fourth saga centered on
the Skywalker family but let me know in
the comments who do you think the
Knights of Ren are do you think that
they're just the extension of the
acolytes of the beyond and do you think
the JJ Abrams is right and they will do
a film about the Knights of read
anything they do will be a lot of fun
I'm sure they'll make a good felt robe
one started out looking like a nightmare
if you hear the stories about how that
came together and they turned it into a
really good film so if they can do that
with the film that's as messy as that
was when they were shooting it and they
can definitely take this dark side
SpecOps team and make a really badass
movie about them so leave all your
requests for Star Wars bonus videos in
the comments below what's going to
happen next is I have some new Infinity
Ward a post Iron Fist just dropped if
you haven't started watching it be sure
to check it out I posted a couple videos
for that so far in all say
congratulations to the latest Star Wars
giveaway winner Devil May Cry you win a
$20 Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details so
there's a new brand that started in this
video I'll just announce the winner when
I post my next Star Wars video while you
wait for that click here for more
episode eight and you can click here to
learn about what
Game of Thrones producers revealed at
the big panel that they did this past
weekend thank you so much watching let
Saibot I'll see you guys in the next
video
me me me me me me
[Music]